جود روسيه للضغط على قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في تحديد مستقبل علاقتها مع
نظام الاسد وتركيا من جهه ومع التحالف
الدولي بقياده الولايات المتحده من جهه
اخرى
بين تركيا وسوريا وضعت قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه امام خيارين وقف التعاون مع
التحالف الدولي والعوده الى نظام الاسد
واستمرار الوضع الحالي كما هو عليه دون
معرفه نتائجها المقبله عليه خاصه في ظل
تهديدات انقر بشان
على المناطق الكرديه شمال سوريا منذ ان
بدات تركيا ضرباتها الجويه على مناطق شمال
سوريا في العشرين منه حاسه قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه حلفتها واشنطن على اتخذه موقف
اكثر حزما لمنع انقره من تنفيذ تهديداتها
محضره سعيده حملات
حقت العناصر داعش التي تقوم بها بالتعاون
مع التحالف الدولي لم يتوقف التنسيق بين
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والتحالف لكنه
تراجع مع تقليص الدوريات وحاجه قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه للتركيز على التصدي للتهديدات
التركيه وحمايه مناطقها منها
الخاص للرئيس الروسي الى سوريا في مقابله
خاصه مع العربيه انما يعيق التقارب بيض
دمشق وانقره حاليا امران رئيسا موضوع
الحدود والانتشار التركي في مناطق شمال
سوريا ثانيا الدعم الشامل الذي تقدمه
تركيا للمعارضه السوريه موضحا في الوقت
نفسه انه لا توجد مشكله في التوقيت بل في
الرغبه بالتقارب بين البلدين والتحرك
باتجاه ذلك